so in one word and just one word can
what is your professional style casual
so I'm here with Kim Swift who's the
creative director for airtight games you
probably might know her better as the
creative genius behind portal can you
tell me a little bit if I've never
played the game portal what what is
portal okay so portal is a first-person
puzzle game where you have control over
this device that makes portals so one's
blue and one's orange and you can see in
one and not the other and you can also
move them wherever you want so let's say
there is a gap that I need to cross and
I can't jump up and get to the other
side I can put one portal next to me and
then I can put one portal on the wall on
the other side of that gap walk three
one and out the other and solve a little
puzzle and it definitely gets more
complicated and it was a it was a
massive commercial success uh he did
pretty well we were certainly surprised
and not only that it was one of the few
games to my understanding that the MoMA
the Museum of Modern Art here in New
York just decided to add I believe it
was 14 video game titles to their
permanent collection somewhere in that
range and among some fairly obvious ones
like you know pac-man they also picked
portal and that must feel pretty good
yeah it was really surprising I mean the
game started out as something that we
initially did as students so the fact
that it's had this amount of success is
always shocking and surprising so let's
talk a little bit about that so you were
going to school at a place called
DigiPen mm-hm just tell people who don't
know what did you Pena's heard a little
bit about it so DigiPen is a technical
school located in Redmond Washington
which is where Microsoft is and Nintendo
of America and they specialize in the
art of creating video games so they have
an art program and they have a computer
science program I graduated from the
computer science program there and you
were working on a project your senior
year you're gonna have to pronounce it
the project is called narbacular drop
that mean it was something that one of
my teammates made up we we wanted to
make sure that we named the game
something memorable and that no
different now I think that no other game
could possibly be named which is just
the case and yeah every year at DigiPen
as part of the curriculum you make a
game so over the course of my four years
there I made four different games with a
team of people and our senior project
was narbacular drop and so then you you
got a meeting with one of the most
powerful men in video games based on
this project gabe newell who if people
don't know knows valve and steam which
is the distribution platform how did
that come about so once a year DigiPen
puts on a senior showcase for all the
graduating students that year and they
bring in lots of different game
companies and to take a look at student
projects and different students they had
little mini interviews set up there and
valve is not far from digipan and so
they sent a couple of representatives
over want to take a look at art and want
to take a look at the programming track
and they thought the game was
interesting and you know after
critiquing it a little bit they said hey
this is a really interesting idea here's
our card and so about a week later we
call them back thinking that hey maybe
we can weasel our way into valve to ask
advice weasel your way in like to ask
advice on how to make our narbacular
drop better because we were going to
submit it so the igf student showcase
later in march so we're like hey these
guys are pros they know what they're
doing let's have them tell us how not to
suck so we took the game there and we
were thinking oh we're just gonna show
it to like maybe two three people and
and the people just kept piling into the
meeting room that we were in and it
stacked up to be I don't know like
20-something people packed into this
room and you know Gabe Newell came in
and sat down and we started demoing the
game and after about 15 minutes Gabe
stops us and asks
hey so what are you guys doing after you
graduate and I answered well hopefully
getting jobs so we can pay back our
student loans and eat and he said okay
and then grabbed a couple people left
and then another 15 minutes passed and
we get escorted into another conference
room and they get you know Gabe asked us
on the spot hey do you want jobs how's
about that's that's the greatest job
search story I've ever it was pretty
incredible we were all like wait what
are you punking us like joke and you
ended up staying there for a while for
like five about five years or so and you
worked on some other game so you're
there yeah
so after portal I worked on left 4 dead
1 & 2 as an artist and a level designer
so we only have time for a couple more
questions but I want to hear a little
bit more what you're doing it airtight
nowadays okay so I the team that I run
is about say 20 people and we like to do
kind of interesting unique puzzle games
the last game that I came out with with
my team I was called Quantum Conundrum
and that came out on PSN XBLA and steam
earlier this summer
still available and it's still awesome
you should pick it up and we're you know
in the process of doing some mobile
games while we're in between larger
profits so a lot of people really really
love video games and would love to find
a job and that's basically you know
think that they would like to do it
professionally from my understandings a
lot of people end up in sort of low end
perhaps dead-end jobs testing games and
so forth what would your advice be to
somebody who really wants to emulate
what you've done make stuff whether it's
in your spare time or at work I mean if
you're in a QA job you know strike up a
conversation with a level designer and
say like hey if I wanted to make a level
could I maybe do that and show it to you
would you look at it you know make
friends and talk to people
you can despise what people might think
the video game industry is really social
you know we're all a big interconnected
group of friends and so just just
talking to people getting advice and
building your portfolio is the best way
possible to get that star job in the
industry